two weeks ago Charlottesville erupted
into chaos violence met the streets as
groups of white supremacists neo-nazis
and far-right demonstrators clashed with
counter protesters some have criticized
and blamed the violence on the police
response police had every opportunity
they're getting overtime pay they're
getting hazard pay
they've got tens of thousand dollars of
equipment per officer and they came out
here and they guard an empty space the
entire day but to better understand why
the demonstration ended up the way it
did you have to understand how riot
control works
the fundamental problem with riot
control is that there are almost never
more riot police than rioters so the
police need to artificially give himself
an advantage part of it is psychological
they make it so rioters think that the
police could defeat them the uniforms
right police wear are intentionally
dehumanizing clad in protective gear
head-to-toe you can hardly tell one
person from the next this creates a
psychological barrier between the police
and the rioters studies have shown that
these uniforms make both the protesters
and the police themselves feel like the
police officers are more powerful than
they are it is also been proven that the
way riot police act increases their
perceived power the officers almost
always March and act in unison when they
act as a collective just like the
protesters they personally feel as if
they have the power of the collective
and the crowd does to the most basic
riot police formation looks like this
with the goal of moving the crowd to
another location the front a salon
slowly advances pushing rioters forward
with their shields and batons they're
followed by a team leader who organizes
the whole group most likely this officer
in the Charlottesville footage right
with the team leader are a few gas
officers you can see one here they have
teargas or pepper spray to deploy over
the front edge Ilan towards any
demonstrators that put up a fight
following them is a group of arrest
officers should the front group
encounter any particularly difficult
rioters they can open up let the
demonstrator through then the arresting
officers can take the troublemaker into
custody finishing is the rear echelon
which protects the group and can sub out
with the front edge salon when they tire
violence happens at rallies because of
three facts crowds are anonymous
anonymity breeds violence and violence
lowers consequences crowds are d
individualizing when you're just one of
a number you don't think or act as much
like an individual person a group of
people all with a common goal and a
common way of thinking breeds a
collective conscience in a crowd people
don't think about consequences the same
way they do when they're on their own
there's a sort of contagion of feeling
just like at a sports game or a
nightclub people act differently than
they normally
because other people do too there's a
sort of wordless peer pressure
individuals subconsciously escalate
their violence to match that of the
leaders people act almost by instinct
and crowds and the individual breaks
down and becomes a part of the
collective when there's widespread
violence individuals are punished less
there's a lower sense of legal
culpability since police often make far
fewer arrests than normal in a riot
authorities can't arrest everyone they
target the leaders the most violent
protesters it's like running from a bear
you don't have to be faster than the
bear you just have to be faster than the
slowest person dozens or perhaps
hundreds of people committed violent
acts in charlottesville that normally
would have resulted in arrests but out
of them only eight people were arrested
police have to be very careful with the
directionality of the protest the
police's goal is to stop or slow the
riot while widespread arrests will often
further ignite the violence in
charlottesville for example if the
police had intervened too strongly the
direction could have turned and members
of both groups could have directed their
violence towards the police police never
want to be perceived as unjust in a riot
scenario that is dangerous so they have
to play a careful balancing act between
too little and too much response so what
went wrong in charlottesville why did it
end up so violent and could the police
have prevented it the unite the right
rally was initially slated to begin at
noon but by 9:00 a.m. there were already
hundreds of demonstrators from both
sides the police were not ready that
early they weren't in there right
uniforms and they didn't have
significant numbers the initial plan was
to physically separate the two groups on
separate sides of Emancipation Park in
downtown Charlottesville there were
barriers set up but nobody seemed to
anticipate the number of people that
showed up the unites the right rally was
in fact a permitted assembly the groups
presence at Emancipation Park was fully
legal but the city did not want them
there specifically the city government
tried to block the demonstration permit
unless the group agreed to hold their
rally at nearby
entire Park a much larger and more open
park nearby
but the rallies organizers successfully
contested this move in court on First
Amendment grounds and was allowed to
hold their rally right there in downtown
Charlottesville there simply was not
enough space for the number of people
who showed up but the fundamental issue
in Charlottesville was numbers
Charlottesville is a small town fewer
than 50,000 people live there and their
police force is correspondingly small
while there were thousands of protesters
the police force had fewer than a
hundred and thirty officers at the same
time the officers working in
Charlottesville were hardly experienced
with riots it's not a big city with
frequent protests this might have been
the first time many officers used their
riot gear in the field they could not
afford for the violence to turn towards
them well the chief of police hasn't
spoken much about his tactics experts
have said that the lack of initial
intervention was likely a conscious
choice to assure that the violence
stayed between protesters and protesters
not between protesters and police
Virginia is an open carry state and many
demonstrators carried assault weapons so
escalated aggression could have turned
the riot even deadlier at around 11:40
a.m. the Virginia State Police declared
the protest an unlawful assembly meaning
was then illegal to participate they
subsequently began the process of
breaking it up carefully now how you
break up a protest is very important
doing it wrong can turn deadly their
first priority was clearing a Mansa
patient park this was both a symbolic
and physical center of the protest they
made it known that the assembly was now
unlawful
then began to slowly work their way
outwards in a uniform fashion pushing
back anyone who put up a fight they
strategically removed the violence
leaders from the public area here you
can see the man in red pulled through
the front line of officers he was likely
brought into custody by the arrest
officers behind the front Ashkelon City
was one of the main escalators there
were other aggressors escalating the
situation like this man with the flag
but the police didn't risk breaking rank
to take him into custody
doing so would expose officers to the
violence of the main crowd tear gas was
used to get the final people out of the
park part of the reason tear gas is so
effective is because the discomfort it
brings makes people stop their
collective action to worry about
themselves
it takes them out of the mass and has
them concentrate on the individual the
park was eventually cleared but the riot
largely continued on the surrounding
streets what was important was that the
police did not try to contain the
demonstrators they did try to contain
the violence but not the people whenever
riot police intervenes they always want
to leave an escape route for the
demonstrators who decide that they've
had enough and want to leave a big
reason why riot police look and act so
intimidatingly is to get rioters to
leave this is in fact exactly how you
stop a riot by getting people to leave
in charlottesville after the clearing of
Emancipation Park many of the alt-right
protestors moved to a secondary location
while the counter protesters started
marching in the surrounding streets
after many hours of violence the groups
did to an extent naturally separate from
each other given the additional space
and pressure of the illegality of the
protest the police had set up a plan to
physically separate the opposing groups
from the start but that was an
idealistic plan it was unrealistic to
think that passionate aggressive
protesters would self-select into their
proper areas it's hard to know exactly
if the police could have done a better
job at preventing violence from analysis
it's clear that they were overwhelmingly
cautious in their techniques which some
may consider merited given their
inexperience with riots and
disadvantaged in numbers the techniques
riot police use are design
to give them an advantage where they
don't have one they're tasked with
preventing damage injuries and death but
they do have to play a careful game of
balance to make sure that violence isn't
immediately directed towards them if
they're overwhelmed with directed
violence they can't effectively prevent
damaging violence the police are in a
position where they're criticized when
they have too little response and
criticize when they have too much
everyone's opinion on the proper level
of response differs so it's almost
impossible for an assembly to occur
without criticism of the police
Charlottesville was an unfortunate
situation where thousands of people all
came into a tiny town to hold one of the
most violent and passionate protests of
this decade the best analysis of the
police's response may be in the outcome
there were no directly preventable
deaths and damage to the city was
minimal the United States and many other
countries around the world are centered
on the idea of free speech
so these police officers have the
unenviable job of deciding where the
demonstration of this unalienable right
stops and where dangerous violent
hooliganism begins on a lighter note
I'll be launching a brand new channel
this Thursday August 31st I don't want
to reveal too much but it's essentially
the continuation of the old twl series
all you should do now is subscribe here
to get the first video right when it
comes out